captain picard helps coach his ancestor
through anxiety while yet another soon
family member is up to no good
everything old is new again literally on
this week's easter egg packed episode of
star trek picard we finally learned the
true mission of adam soong in fly me to
the moon though he initially claims that
he is out to cure his daughter's
debilitating genetic disorder which
makes sunlight and water poisonous to
her it seems that his actual goals are a
bit more sinister
i poured my heart into you
i let myself believe
you were the one
after his daughter corey gets curious
she discovers files on his computer that
reveal an alarming truth she is not his
first daughter
he's had many more all of whom were
apparently grown in a lab and died
before reaching maturity some survived
until childhood but she seems to be the
first to make it to adulthood this dark
mission mirrors that of his descendant
eric sung who appeared in the star trek
enterprise three-part story that began
with borderland and the series fourth
and final season in that episode it has
revealed that eric soon also played by
brett spiner has taken possession of
genetically modified embryos left over
from earth's eugenics wars and raised
them into adulthood while screening out
any defects it appears here that adam
sung is doing the same or similar
however adam isn't having nearly as much
success perhaps due to the more
primitive science of his time after all
adam's experimentations occur more than
a hundred years before eric's there's
still much to be learned about adam
soon's dirty work but it's clear that
eric soon was not alone in his family's
desire to grow the perfect human
at the gala renee picard feels
overwhelmed by the spotlight and
retreats to a quieter room to be alone
while q disguised as her therapist
encourages her to back out of the
mission her descendant jean-luc picard
is there to ensure she follows through
he follows her and finds her in a
hallway commemorating the history of
earth space flight from the early
orbiters all the way up to contemporary
spacecraft in the fictional 2024. there
we see many models including the 1969
moonlander and the shango x1 which renee
picard will pilot on the upcoming europa
mission when the supercards meet and
renee is feeling too distraught to speak
jean-luc implores her to look up and
tell him about the ship hanging in the
museum above them the ship we see is no
stranger to star trek though has never
been seen in an actual episode the ship
in question is an ov-165 which can be
seen in the opening credits of star trek
enterprise originally designed to show
mankind's slow evolution from apollo 11
to the nx-01 enterprise its appearance
here is the first time we've seen a
model of it i call her spike because
she's got these kick-ass aero spike
engines that use less fuel
it seems the writers of star trek picard
are respecting the canon history of
space exploration in earth's fictional
present day including the ov-165 shuttle
in addition to the shango x1 the apollo
11 capsule and the ov-165 shuttle
viewers glimpse another space vessel in
the hallway museum when the two per
cards converse this one is one that trek
fans should recognize that they are
familiar with the original series
episode the changeling we already got
one easter egg referencing that episode
when the name jackson roykirk popped up
at the tail end of episode four
jackson roy kirk captain
james kirk
yes
similar
here roy kirk's pioneering space probe
called nomad makes an appearance but the
model of the ship sitting clearly over
picard's shoulder throughout their
conversation though we get only a
fleeting glimpse of the model on screen
promotional stills released ahead of the
episode's premiere showed more this
includes a large signage accompanying
the museum piece which displays
information about the model confirming
the vessel as nomad the spacecraft
itself would be lost on its mission only
to turn up centuries later when it's
found by captain kirk and the uss
enterprise after merging with another
probe of alien design when rafi meets up
with rios during the gala she noticed
his upbeat attitude and connects it to
his meeting to racer she can't help but
warn him about the perils of falling in
love in 2024
because when you meet someone from a
different century
the relationship is kind of built on
lies
while this is definitely good advice for
rios it feels like a nod to previous
star trek time travel episodes in which
one of the main cast falls in love with
someone from the past in the original
series episode city on the edge of
forever captain kirk becomes
romantically involved with edith keeler
a woman in 1930 new york and is forced
to let her die to preserve the timeline
he again becomes linked to a woman in
1986 after traveling backing time in the
film the voyage home leading to a
complicated conversation in a restaurant
where he must dance around his true
origins
don't tell me
you're from outer space
no i'm from iowa i only work in outer
space
in the star trek voyager two-parter
futures end it's tom paris who must cut
short a budding romance with sarah
silverman's character rayne robinson who
clearly has the hots for him because he
has to return to the 24th century even
in deep space nine jadzia dax's quasi
romance with 21st century industrialist
chris brinner was doomed to fail though
in that episode she was mostly just
using him to basically bust her friends
out of jail
either way rafi is right rios ought to
know better than to consider a
time-crossed romance and there are
plenty of examples from the past why
that's the case
while corey searches the internet for
information on her father adam sung she
pulls up several news sites with damning
headlines one calls her father a mad
scientist while others notice violation
of the shenzhen conventions however an
easy to miss headline on another news
site hints at events we may have seen
before on a new sidebar a headline for a
separate and related story reads
tensions rise as conflict reaches 30
days while another mentions unrest has
caused peace talks involving the
president to stall with the episode set
in 2024 this feels like another
reference to the deep space nine episode
past tense which foreshadowed a time of
great social unrest
the century leading up to first contact
was just rife with chaos
past tense also features star trek crew
members sent back to 2024 and it's
prominently noted that the year is full
of strife with riots and civil unrest
occurring everywhere from san francisco
to europe in one key scene guests at a
dinner party remark about a conflict
between the so-called neotruskies and
violent student protesters one guest
even mentions that she cancelled a trip
to the swiss alps amid the violence that
violence being mentioned here may a
similarly violent end for this season of
star trek picard
europe is falling apart
well at least we don't have to worry
about that kind of thing here
don't count on it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you